hello everyone and welcome back to
versus the show that takes beautiful
works of art tosses them into an arena
and challenges one to emerge victorious
by any means necessary including a leg
sweep i think either of our hit
streaming shows featured today will have
a problem duking it out for glory
they've seen everything from scary
paranormal creatures to intimidating
martial arts masters and through it all
they've allowed us viewers to nibble on
the nectar of nostalgia it's cobra kai
taking on stranger things right now on
verses in one corner you have cobra kai
and it's sunny southern california
setting that sees old favorites from the
karate kid franchise ushering a new
generation of underdogs hoping to
overcome obstacles like ruthless bullies
the passage of time and eccentric family
members very nice way to talk to your
she didn't mean it that way yeah just
tell me i meant it that way in the other
corner it's the residence of hawkins
indiana featured in stranger things
particularly a group of young underdogs
hoping to overcome obstacles like
ruthless netherworld bullies wacky
scientists and eccentric family members
one show reminds us how much fun we used
to have in the 80s the other takes that
80s fun and pontiac firebirds its way
into modern times pontiac
firebird
only one will be crowned the best around
here's how we'll determine a winner
round one tomato meter slash audience
score round two characters round three
iconic moments round four dodge ball and
then we'll do a wild card round that
could involve anything from which show
has the more concerned mom the more
roguish father figure or the most
nosebleeds that actually would be a
really good battle both shows have now
found a home on netflix although they
took wildly different paths to get there
so get on your karate key make sure the
walkie-talkie has fresh batteries and
let's prepare to duke it out against
demogorgons valley nerdu wells and i
guess you know normal high school stuff
we're still trying to get into college
here right that's the goal thanks for
sharing didn't know it's cobra kai
taking on stranger things with both
shows on the precipice of exciting new
seasons fire up some eggo waffles and
face kicks are legal here let's get it
on round one tomato meter slash audience
score right off the bat we head into the
round it's determined by what the
critics had to say about your show on
the tomato meter and also what you the
verified audience felt about each season
and depending on how you look at it
either show could have a strong
advantage in terms of output cobra kai
is about to launch its fifth season
later this year meanwhile stranger
things as season four so will that extra
year of ratings help or hurt the martial
arts folk from the san fernando valley
the fourth season of a given show
usually isn't the highest rated such as
with the sopranos or breaking bad and
sometimes we never even get a fourth
season as was the case with alf the dude
went off to become a monk and we never
heard from him again
interesting concept both cobra kai and
stranger things kicked their runs off in
style and with great grades cobra kai
season 1 is a perfect 100 on the tomato
meter while stranger things landed at 97
things evened out after season two which
saw cobra kai fall to 90 and stranger
things hold on to a 94 but then season
three happened and stranger things
dropped into the 80s not the decade that
it loves so much but the percentile on
the tomato meter
[Laughter]
season 3 is the hawkins crew lowest
rating thus far at 89 percent while
cobra kai maintained its discipline by
notching 90 again and now we get to that
all-important fourth season trailers and
rumors on the information super highway
suggest that season four of stranger
things could be its biggest and boldest
yet but cobra kai has already had its
quadriceps
that's not a word it's it's not a word i
don't know what that is but get off at
pronto and it landed like a crane kick
to the nose earning a 95 on the tomato
meter before we get into the averages to
see who's making it out of this round
with the first point of the match kind
of feels like we're in the all valley
karate tournament let's take a look at
the netflix ratings for each series fun
fact netflix rarely if ever releases
their numbers and keeps them guarded in
a vault next to the actual ark of the
covenant but i snuck into their holding
facility and managed to extract some
sensitive data before i got caught or i
believe what's being reported on the
internet
according to the flicks stranger things
season 3 was watched for a whopping
562 million hours in its first month of
release cobra kai counters by having its
season 4 witness to the tune of 120
million hours within its first three
days and if you think those are gaudy
numbers they're both looking up at squid
game which reportedly hit everybody
sitting down for this
1.65 billion hours after its first 28
days and i think i waited until like day
30 to watch it so that's you know more
total hours remember when netflix used
to send us dvds hey honey get the mail
maybe how to lose a guy in 10 days is in
there nobody likes some mr sniffles
i hate mr sniffles all right enough
preamble let's finish this round off and
see who gets the early lead stranger
things has an overall average of 93 on
the tomato meter you know what else does
alph he's quick i'll give him that no
i'm kidding he doesn't have a rating but
koverkai is also 93 across all seasons
on the tomato meter it's a tie which
means we go to sudden death let's go
no coin flip determines possession here
we're just gonna look at the audience
score according to you the people
stranger things has an overall average
of 91 percent on this metric and now for
the win cobra kai has a 92
on the audience score
wow that's a huge win especially
considering that the highest rated
karate kid movie on the tomato meter is
the og at 89 percent meanwhile the
karate kid part three you know the one
with all the banzai stuff 13
rotten yikes somebody's talking about
[ __ ] did i just ruin the party for
everyone i'm so sorry but cobra kai does
get the win in round one by the slimmest
of margins and goes up one to nothing no
mercy
round two characters cobra kai keeps on
kicking ass and now sports an early lead
but you can never count out a ragtag
group of bike aficionados from the
midwest especially ones that specialize
in epic dungeons and dragons quests
now we'll take a look at the best
characters from each show and see how
they stack up against one another
stranger things sports a scrappy group
of kids but cobra kai features the
return of some of our favorite big
screen heroes and villains from when we
ourselves were kids johnny lawrence has
owned a special part of the zeitgeist
ever since the bully role inhabited by
william zapka in 1984 as the karate kid
hit theaters and ever since debate has
raged over whether he was actually the
bad guy in that film or if he was just
the victim of an opportunistic daniel
sun and a very skewed storytelling angle
in fact it's the prism of johnny's
perspective that inspired creators john
hurwitz hayden schlossberg and josh heel
to come up with cobra kai when we meet
lawrence and larusso in the show their
life pass couldn't have been more
divergent daniel is a successful
southland car dealer johnny struggling
to get by
this dynamic lends sympathy to lawrence
regardless of how you saw the events of
the karate kid play out and it adds a
healthy dose of fun house mirror
memories when we see the two interact as
adults cobra kai also taps the film
franchise well to bring back legendary
baddies like john crease and even
daniel's original sweetheart america's
favorite babysitter elizabeth shu oh
thank you but whereas cobra kai was able
to spring a new well from older source
material stranger things took us back to
the 1980s with a fresh set of folks so
familiar that we felt like we've already
known them and it's the kids leading the
charge 11 and mike played by millie
bobby brown and finn wolfhard prove that
these young actors are more than just
super fun names to say out loud they're
endearing protagonists from vastly
different worlds that team up to fight
creatures from another dimension and go
through puberty
so the degree of difficulty between
these two shows i'd say it's about even
they're flanked by dustin and lucas who
round out the d d loving buddies
searching for their fellow friend will
byers in season one the adults are more
than just monotone peanuts teachers and
stranger things though sometimes the
kids would be better off to ignore their
elders as it turns out david harbor as
sheriff hopper is note perfect as a
gruff small town law enforcement type
who turns out to have his own tragic
past a biting wit and a killer dad bod
seriously i don't know how or why
everyone suddenly nominated hopper as a
sex symbol but as a guy who works out
occasionally in his garage i will
happily co-sign that sentiment no stop
it's all you i'm a puppet you're the
master winona ryder is also
appropriately over the top as will's mom
who loses her son and then her mind
trying to get him back what's great
about cobra kai is that they simply
don't rely on our memories to get by
they create a new generation of karate
kids from scratch miguel robbie hawk
samantha just to name a few and
samantha's daddy yeah that's daniel's
son and they all carve out unique
identities keeping us invested in the
show alongside their counterparts from a
previous generation and while cobra kai
has always walked the line away from
just being a spoof there's plenty of
comedy to be had particularly thanks to
daniel's employees at the car dealership
wait is this the karate guy the guy from
the tournament
oh there's a guy who's actually kicked
dana dude plays the reliable anush and
brett ernst is louis daniel's nerdywell
cousin and they shine by giving us laugh
out loud moments to go with the engaging
storylines but cobra kai is still
predicated on the folks we brought back
for another shot at telling socal
martial arts tales stranger things
though it borrowed heavily from
inspirations ranging from stephen king
to ghostbusters blessed are netflix
accounts with holy original characters
our gaggle of kids their adult foils and
maybe what elevates it from other shows
is everyone else who could forget steve
or billy freaking barb for goodness
sakes toss in some veterans like matthew
modine and paul reiser and you have
yourself the primary reason why stranger
things keep sucking hours out of our
eyeballs the cast makes this stuff
believable and unlike cobra kai we're
meeting these hawkins denizens all for
the very first time making for a most
impressive accomplishment stranger
things wins round two and we're tied at
one apiece
iconic moments sure we love the casts
and the stories and the ooey gooey
nostalgia but what really gets us to
continually binge these two programs is
the memorable scenes and incredible
sequences that shock awe and inspire us
for stranger things having the netflix
boost right out of the gate allowed the
show runners some coin to dream up some
truly terrifying special effects-laden
instances that we're still reeling from
most of which feature the otherworldly
abilities of 11.
to witness the evolution of her role is
both a credit to millie bobby brown's
performance and the frightening
situations in which she's thrust into in
season one she flips a van season two
sees her close the gate and in the next
season she removes a parasite from her
leg all moments that last with us and
evidence that she deserves a waffle
party just as much as anyone from
severance by the way have you all seen
severance
look at you all dewy mouth
you never smile at me it's also fun to
watch the chemistry between 11 and her
adoptive father figure hopper he's such
a typical dad even when the scenario is
anything but ordinary like when they're
hiding out from everything in a remote
forest or when 11 and mike experience
all those things that teenagers feel
together while trying to more or less
you know save the world uh-oh
i think we're in trouble they always
tell you that high school might be the
best four to six years of your life and
it almost never is but how are any of
these young folks gonna follow up what
they did when they were teenagers
they've earned the right to wear their
varsity jackets forevermore and also i
don't think they should have to pay
taxes just my two cents
you've outdone yourself cobra kai scores
big points in multiple ways its own new
crop of school kids do a tremendous job
of keeping us invested in their
storylines to balance out their parents
generation even if it is a familiar
setting the all valley tournament which
in this show makes march madness look
like a local spelling bee is its own
character and has given us momentous
showdowns such as miguel versus robbie
at the end of season one and in season
four we got highlights like robbie
versus eli and sam versus tori but at
its core the karate kid was always about
overcoming bullies not just at karate
tournaments but anywhere in studio city
at school like the massive brawl in
season two or when miguel takes on a
flock of sad sacks in season one but zap
that i am i still love a good johnny
redemption story and while he has
trouble getting out of his own way most
of the time the first instance that he
defends miguel from a group of
neighborhood ruffians early in season
one still stands tall i also love the
complexity of johnny and daniel's modern
relationship the twists and turns are
unexpected and always welcome who would
have thought we'd ever see them train
together in the same dojo aiming to take
down john crease this show's so fun man
those are good times but enjoyable romp
though it may be cobra kai simply can't
keep pace with stranger things when it
comes to stakes i give all the props to
the all valley tournament but in indiana
we're talking about the fate of the
universe as we know it so every time we
get an emotional heartstring tug like
watching will and his mom communicate by
christmas lights or bob making the
ultimate sacrifice it sticks to our ribs
and the epic action of mike heading off
a cliff only to be rescued by 11 and the
general look and feel of the upside down
it's all too much for another show to
conquer plus we get to see
1987-11 when that store was peak
everything it's good now try the
taquitos but how great did that vintage
pepsi can look stranger things takes
round three and suddenly has a two to
one lead over cobra kai
terrific
round four dodgeball all right i might
have set some false expectations for
this next round when i announced it
unfortunately none of either set of kid
casts responded to my repeated evites to
play dodgeball on behalf of their
respective shows but that's not why this
round is called dodgeball you see
there's a movie called dodgeball and
it's 71 percent fresh in the tomato
meter and its subtitle is a true
underdog story hence what this round is
all about who's the bigger underdog
whoever came the tougher set of odds and
obstacles to achieve success this can be
interpreted two ways the events depicted
in the show or the goings-on behind the
scenes that got these programs the green
light to say hi to the world become
monstrous hits and wind up with the
ultimate honor being judged by me on
versus the preferred artistic combat
show since 2018. seriously in terms of
what we see on screen it would appear
that stranger things has the advantage
simply because of what your astute host
noted in the previous round we're saving
a planet here technically just a town
but soon the state the continent things
could have gotten really bad really
quick meanwhile cobra kai also tells the
story of underdogs much in the same vein
as its grandpappy the karate kid that
seminal film was directed by john d
avelson who also did rocky it's a story
about rising up to fulfill your destiny
even as those around you doubt your
abilities to do so and while the all
valley tournament is a crucial milestone
of success just ask johnny lawrence oh
man of much more import is seeing a
school kid who gets picked on conquering
his demons and putting bullies in their
place it may not be saving a planet but
it's determining a path to future
success to one's own life which is no
small feat plus stranger things has an
ace in the hole the supernatural
abilities of eleven if this was just
mike lucas and dustin looking for will
in season one we're probably screwed and
we wouldn't have even had a star court
mall to hang out at by season three
because everything in hawkins would have
been decimated by dark forces but 11
being able to match witch with a
demogorgon evens the playing field we've
lost lots of favorites to the upside
down over the years but as long as 11 is
in the ball game we got a fighting shot
however when pitching the show stranger
things to networks creators the duffer
brothers didn't have any precocious
youngster with a bloody nose to help
curry favor before it landed at netflix
their concept had been rejected by over
a dozen outlets you are o four six
popeye no one seemed interested in
footing the bill for a project that had
plenty of 80s memories but no
established ip of its own off of which
to grow a mythology cobra kai had the
luxury of a beloved brand with the
karate kid but that also presented
another challenge to herwitz swashburg
and healed when attempting to find a
home for their beloved pitch would the
cast of a 1984 film be interested in
re-inhabiting these characters do they
even care anymore legacies were at stake
and if cobra kai was amiss it might have
spelled the end for karate kid fans the
once mighty mythology exiting with amir
whimper
also they had to find a studio willing
to make this risk of a memory lane
stroll while netflix was already an
established streaming giant by the time
stranger things rolled around youtube
was just hatching from the egg in terms
of original content and as it turns out
youtube originals and cobra kai's fates
were intertwined and word of mouth began
to spread slowly but surely as for
stranger things that word of mouth is
more accurately described as a social
media wildfire blazing a path to glory
on its debut weekend it seemed like the
show came out of nowhere yet everyone
was intrigued by this concept and it
quickly became a race to see who could
finish season one first so we wouldn't
get spoiled by our friends quite an
uphill climb but once stranger things
debuted its half-life would never be in
doubt again that wasn't the case for
cobra kai despite rave reviews from
critics and a positive fan response
youtube had decided to go in a different
creative correction leaving kai without
a parachute until netflix ponied up and
even now as we look at these two shows
that are about fulfilling potential and
overcoming extreme odds stranger things
feels like the establishment and cobra
kai the young upstart even though
they're both fond of the exact same time
period stranger things has huge effects
set pieces and budgets that can take
anything on the page and make it feel
real although it's entering its fifth
season cobra kai still feels lucky to be
here maybe it's us the audience that are
the fortunate ones through years of
dormancy a fighty youtube project and
now a beloved netflix hit cobra kai
continues to maintain its initial charm
the ultimate underdog story it was a
bold move cotton and the average joes
would be proud cobra kai takes the point
in round four and we're back tied two to
two that word cotton and now it's time
for the wild card round don't make me do
this yes i am referring to the impending
decision that i will have to make in
order to settle the score between two
beloved shows once and for all or at
least until we see their next season but
when mark ellis is backed into a corner
and is well aware that no matter what he
decides he will be met with intense
scrutiny i pawned as much of that
responsibility on to the fans yeah i did
some fan polls on my social media
account at mark ellis live asking the
simple question to my loyal followers
which show do you like better cobra kai
or stranger things good luck this was
especially daunting for me because i was
just recovering from having one of my
accounts hacked the week before was it a
mythological creature from the upside
down or maybe terry silver the bottom
line is i'm never selling playstation 5s
for 50 bucks ever i play nintendo wii
funny enough one fan the movie dimension
actually replied to my poll with a south
park gift that said don't make me do
this ah fans they write the whole show
while i sip lemonade in a hammock
unfortunately even when i rely on my
gutsy fans to bail me out sometimes even
they can't find a true consensus dominic
gonzalez says while cobra kai brings
heightened suspense and drama there's
just something about the mystery of
stranger things that keeps me on edge
and i love it dominic's take was
countered by an old ally former producer
of this very show alex pastrana now he
has a cool podcast you all should check
out and he voted on the side of cobra
kai how so where do i turn next well the
shows are based on our fondness for
memories past so how's about i look back
as to how i found these programs like
everyone else i binged stranger things
on its debut weekend i had no
recollection of ever hearing about this
concept and i can't even recall seeing a
trailer what i do remember is being on
the road at the cincinnati funny bone
that weekend which i actually think is
technically in kentucky i don't have
time to look at a map because i was
telling jokes and searching for will
byers and i was so blown away by how
engaging the kids were and how
intriguing the story was cobra kai was a
much slower burn for me i was never the
biggest karate kid fan but i never took
issue with it either my friends kept
telling me that this new show was right
up my alley but it wasn't until i saw an
image of adult present-day johnny
lawrence from season one wearing a van
halen shirt that was the icebreaker for
me and it's been love ever since both
shows are now appointment television for
this guy along the lines of recent hits
like ozark insecure better call saul
atlanta and any live sporting contest
and since social media left me in a
virtual deadlock twitter said stranger
things instagram said cobra kai and
facebook said i could lose 30 pounds in
two weeks it's all on my shoulders
something's never changed and while
cobra kai has been able to continually
impress me with new wrinkles in its
storyline for both the kids and adults
stranger things has yet to live up to
the promise of season one i thought
season three was a solid rebound from a
lackluster sophomore effort but it still
feels like some magic is lacking so
while i had the confidence that the
series will close out with a mighty bang
for now i have to side with those strip
mall karate dojos not far from where
molly the wonder dog and i currently
live cobra kai wins the round and thus
earns another underdog victory by taking
the match winner there may be cobra kai
fans cheering from the raptors but all i
hear right now are the booze raining
down from all you stranger things
loyalists so remember no mercy i'm sorry
that was somebody else talking i'm just
saying we're doing this for fun it's my
opinion and it's bound to change after
we see the next voyage of cobra kai or
the farewell tourist ranger things both
shows deserve to be appreciated for the
outliers that they are the perfect blend
of nostalgic fondness and original
storytelling with a dash of humor and a
pinch of drama top it off with a few
delicious member berries and you got
yourself a good night of streaming ahead
now it's your turn did you vote on my
social media polls wait what you're not
even following me i do put out the bad
signal from time to time so hit that
follow button for mark ellis live and
again whatever i say do not buy a ps5
from me keep it right here at rotten
tomatoes for all the latest and greatest
in the world of movies tv cobras and
things thanks for watching this edition
of versus until next time i'm mark ellis
saying lego my eggo and i'll sweep your
leg
you